I
PHILADELIAIC
LDDYKYFAON  TSIDENT
IMPEACHMENT.
UKIAINNDSLIDE ECAS TE 40D
MI U.S
CONGRESS FOR HATIO FEN
N .
O PROJECT UNITY ANANRICAN PRESI
THELTEBIDENS, ALEXANNDMA
G  CALL BY
ENSKYYAND THE REST IWHAT
. ASSISTANCE
AND
COMEDIANN TRANSFD
FROM THE AMERICAN FOOTNOTE TO
TH OD UM OFFICE.
BUT THE QUESTIONF WHHEVIEL P S N
USVASION.
DR 8th OF LAST YEAR
AFTER MEETING WITHUTINLDERS THA
TRO UKRA  O
F YEAR
WH AC'LE PENOOPS
S FLEEE
COUNTR B REPLIED.AT'S AORHEN
AMERD RUSSIANS
TOLD THE B TO BERG
DEPLOY NATO IN WE'RIN
FEBRUARY 4thY EW DAY
GE A FRENCH
OUNATO, RAINE IN MANY
AIES SUPPORT
SO PUTIN KNE T
JUIKY,T  WE ARE DEFENDING OUALON
PORFOUWORLD
OM A DISTANCE.
THIS, THE DEST  ARTILLERY
ULTIMATE ARGUMENT FOR D
HE ALSAPPEALE  SG NV
OAHE FEN
WE WILL GIVE YOU WEAPONSTHLYHEYA
NOIN
N 13 BORDER GUAR
ONSL SURRENDER TO RUSSN NARDS,
WARSHIP, GO "F"  LL 13 THEN DD A
BOMBARDMENT DEFINEPRIDANNOUNCEDE
HOLD ON FO
NOR TH T WELL INLO RUSSIA.
UKRAINIANSIGHTINFO.
RUSSIANS ARET OF A F DICTATOR.
AND THERE S OF THAT ORT BUCKLIN.
, PUTIN NEEDED TGI
SPA PUBLIC
A
TWO D  UKRAINEHI
SUBTERFUGEOR THE
TV STARS
ANS HAVE BEE
AL
THURSDAY NIGHT, SOMETHONCEINFAA.
N  SA WARNING FRUS  WOULDJAIL
S I DID NOT SPESED ON SOCIALND
.
TE AVOID
ENEMY HAT  HE SAIDTOE INFORMATIE
ONEMY FAMILY ISART NUMBERWO.
R ON THE FIRST TO
A DEFENSIV
MEASURE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT T.
MEMBEBUT ITRESET
NERVOUES PHB.
BABLENOU
TTHWART  PY
BUT 20 YEARST-9/11ICANS ARLANDT'
WHE CAL  ION.HAOMEDIAN
THIS HO MY WEBSITE AT .COM ANS
WEEK'S SURVEY QUESTION, LD
NATO WAR?
RETIREARMYUTENANT COLONEL
ALEXANDER ND FORME
HE'S AUTHOR OF BEST-SELLINAL SIT
MEMOIR "HERE RIGHT M
E THIS FOR
AMERICA COULD HAVE
MORE.
COVIND
BIDEN TPOLICY IS 20US
VY NARROWLY
BOUNDED WHAT TWENKING ABOU
TH ANNOUNCEMENTHATED  DECEMBER,
HAPPERS F A SPIRALING OF
BIL  ESIDENT BIDEN TO
THATINSTEA
AMBIGUITLIT WEHAONMAINTA IRDS TO
OE TATHE
DETERRENT, I  YELLOGHT.
BIDEN'S FAULT.
IGHA
CE PROVISIONE
H MORENSE CAPABILITIES.E SORELY
OFIPS F E COAST OF ODE O
AND WE WERE TOOWINONQUT THE
FACT TRE
LEADINGHEWORLD.HIGH
LENSKYY  DY INSPIRING.
WLD CHARG
DET AUTHORITARIA P.
E ILL THINGS WE CAIT'SFOLDING T.
RAN ARMED
SI
THE BIGGS ARE IN T
THAT'S ALSO KYIV.
WITH AITR NSE THEY COULDTA
EQUALIZE.
THEY'RE NO AGAIN RUSSIRC
BUT IT'
GOING TOG. SULD THIN
TO DEFTHAR ALTITUDEMS. THEM HOW
TARGETHE TE.HICLES
PROBABLY NOTHE TARGETS THAT
ARE HEUT
DEEP TO SUPPORLED
INRCTHAT ARE
SHOCKINGARE UNITS THATTION. RE K
OVING TOO
FAST.
T LOGISTICS
TAIL.
E TO BER CAN START
TARGETING THOSTELY ASTILRD SLOGB
IMIGHT HERE CONTIN TO URTHAT.
>> I SHARE YOUSE OE INIRFROM
ITUTS, I THI IY
GHT, MAYBE NOTOR
FORE AS AN
THAT TELEP CI WEPT BD I RE-R
TRANSCRIPT AND RURSSMENT FROM YA
HE
RE.
INED TO REECT UNITY AN
STS OF THE ITED STATES, TO PREV?
>> THAT'S Y
MAJOR OPRT
ENKRENTE
INTARTHU
REN PAUSHE TRUMP ADD    TISSURE
WARS TT THE
THAT IIN
PROTESTS,ITH S.W.I.F.T. E OFHAK